great story challenges that assumption
kind of a sad story but it's funny
nonetheless there's a painting in Spain
this painting done by the baroque
painter bitola Mae Esteban Maria it's a
painting of the Virgin Mary and the
painting needed to be restored so the
owner of this painting went to an
amateur painting restorer and so he said
can you fix up the painting the first
attempt was absolutely disastrous
completely destroyed the painting it
took this beautiful baroque painting of
the Blessed Virgin and turned it into
what looks like a third graders
assignment so then they tried again made
it look like a first writers assignment
it got worse then they tried again and
it looks like a three-year-old finger
painted it they took a beautiful work of
art from hundreds of years ago and made
it worse and then worse and then worse
that's not progress that would be the
opposite of I would be regressed I
believe and this has happened before
actually in Spain again there's a fresco
of Jesus in 2012 and an amateur painter
this woman Cecilia Jimenez attempted to
restore the h.a Omo painting and the
same same results I mean it just became
this blotchy mess they took a beautiful
painting and then and then just turned
it into what what could be finger paint
that's the perfect encapsulation of our
culture that's what we are doing we're
tearing down great men we're tearing
down works of art now one of the black
lives matter lead activists is calling
for people to smash stained-glass
windows and statues and and icons at
churches and that is happening at least
in Europe I don't know if it's happened
yet in America I guess they did to face
that they tried to burn it down and then
to face the st. John's Church all of
this is happening and we're
congratulating ourselves all the
beautiful art all the beautiful cultural
the beautiful political system all the
beautiful civilization we are tearing it
to shreds lighting it on fire all on the
premise that we're so much better than
the people who built it we're so much
better watch us torch it
and yet the people who are doing it are
so divorced from reality they are so
lost in their own make believe in their
own fantasy that they can't even see it
they think that that actually reality is
the opposite of what it is they think up
is down good is bad and and law is
lawlessness and on and on and on we're
living in an upside-down world and
something tells me that just like that
painting restoration things are gonna
get worse and worse and worse and I hope
one day they get better but for the near
future I think I mentioned this
yesterday the only way out is going to
be group
[Music]
[Music]